filière alive bonjour nous sommes en
direct ce vendredi matin pour faire un
nouveau point sur l'ukraine sur ce qui
se passe en ukraine la situation en
ukraine chez avec alexis faire chaque
bonjour alexis adjoint au pôle actu on
va parler avec vous de tout ce qui se
passe grâce aux cartes du service
infographie que vous pouvez voir
derrière nous à côté de nous voilà pour
faire vraiment le point sur ce qui se
passe tout au long de ce live vous
n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser vos
questions on essaiera d'y répondre au
mieux bien évidemment on peut commencer
par une question un peu général alexis
quelle est la situation est ce qu ont
varié d'un acte ii de ce conflit
ukrainien c'est un acte 2 bat on le voit
tout de suite sur la carte honoria du
bleu au sud et à l'est du mans vient du
orange en fait qu'est ce que ça montre
l'acteur 1 donc avait commencé le 24
février c'était une invasion générale de
l'ukraine y avait un front nord il ya un
fond et un front sud et notamment le le
front au nord c'était les trois
persévérer vers kiev et ça s'est terminé
aujourd'hui les combats se concentrent
principalement sur le fond de l'ess
notamment avec le le don basque est
vraiment là la pointe s de l'ukraine et
puis le le fond du sud est mais le
l'invasion mais a changé de dimension si
vous voulez donc c'est plus tout à fait
la même guerre attention c'est pas une
guerre qui est moins forte ou moins
intenses ça reste pour les russes la
plus importante opération de militaires
depuis 1945 je rappelle toujours le
l'ukraine c'est plus grand que la france
et 40 millions d'habitants et même si on
prend simplement le dombass honte on
voit le contour en gris c'est la ligne
grise à l'est et bien le nom basse c'est
quasiment deux fois la belgique est par
ailleurs c'est la zone qui
historiquement était la plus peuplée du
crâne donc voilà c'est une ça reste une
vaste opération militaire mais qui se
concentre dans l'est oui on rappelle que
le ce conflit a commencé il ya
maintenant plus de 10 à plus de deux
mois il ya plus de deux mois maintenant
on parlera bien évidemment du dombass
qui concentrent aujourd'hui toutes les
toutes les attentions on peut parler
peut-être de ce qui s'est passé
hier à kiev où les forces russes ne sont
plus présentes autour de la ville comme
c'était le cas précédemment mais par
contre qu'ils ont effectué une frappe
sur place lorsqu'il faut bien voir c'est
qu'il ya encore quelques semaines quand
la bataille de kiev était encore engagé
à envoyer évidemment il n'y avait plus
de dirigeants qui venait à kiev on se
souvient que même les ambassades avait
été délocalisé à lviv c'est à l'extrême
ouest de l'ukraine là on a complètement
changé de cas non seulement les
ambassades sont revenus à kiev mais on
voit une sorte de défilé de deux
dirigeants de chefs d'état on a vu ce
matin l'ambassadeur français l'a dit
peut être que macro envisagerait un
voyage lui aussi à kiev et donc qui hier
c'était le secrétaire général de l'onu
antonio guterres s est donc est venue
notamment
voyez à l'ouest de la capitale
verbund chabot revenu en cas etc ce sont
ces villes il y avait été laissée
localité capturer parlera par les russes
qui étaient tout proches de nokia
c'était toute la zone bleue ça
correspond à l'avancé maximale défenseur
russe et bien en se retirant les
ukrainiens sont revenus dans ces
territoires ils ont découvert il ya
plusieurs semaines de cela maintenant
des charniers des massacres de civils
avec toutes les questions que ça que ça
pose est ce qu'il s'agit de crimes de
guerre sans aucun doute crimes contre
l'humanité peut-être génocide
juridiquement c'est improbable mais on
voit que c'est le terme qui est le plus
utilisé par les ukrainiens et par leurs
alliés pourquoi parce que politiquement
c'est le terme le plus fort après
juridiquement la vraie question c'est ce
qu'on est passé plutôt de crimes de
guerre retrouve dans quasiment tous les
conflits à des crimes contre l'humanité
pour ça il faut montrer qu'il ya une
veulent on est enfin qu'est des
massacres à grande échelle visant la
population civile voilà mais ça c'est la
justice internationale ça prendra des
années mais là le temps pour l'instant
c'est pas un temps judiciaire ça tangue
politique et donc goûter res à kiev
c'était quelque chose effectivement les
russes qui en même temps d'ailleurs
l'assument font une frappe de précision
à kiev alors officiellement ils ont visé
un local spatiale
certes ça c'est l'objectif militaire
mais l'objectif politique derrière c'est
de dire il ya bovins le patron de l'ol
nus à kiev on tape quand même et donc
c'est une mine une humiliation à dire
pour pour l'onu c'est c'est aussi une
façon de montrer que on est en sécurité
nulle part en ukraine il ya eu même des
frappes dans l'ouest du pays aujourd'hui
les rues sont encore capables de frapper
partout dans le pays mais c'est aussi
pour pour montrer ce que je vous disais
circulent l'espèce de retour à la
normalité c'est-à-dire que kiev
redevient la capitale vraiment
sûr de l'ukraine avec un défilé de chefs
d'état a tout d'un coup ça rappelle que
le pays dans son ensemble est bien en
guerre et ça pour les rues si important
de le montrer pourquoi pas que ça passe
pour une défaite pour que l'acte 1 passe
pour une défaite alors qu'en réalité on
verra l'acteur a été défaite pour les
russes mais voilà hausse et tenir un
discours qui qu'ils soient entendent abl
effectivement donc on a parlé de on a
parlé de kiev qui est maintenant toutes
les troupes russes on peut le dire sont
partis alors maintenant ça fait
plusieurs semaines maintenant ça fait 3
3 plus trois semaines plus trois
semaines maintenant on va le voir sur
cette carte alors c'est pas sur celle là
mais c'est sur celle ci voilà donc tous
ces jeunes bleus c'est des hommes qui
ont finalement été récupérée mais pas
forcément en terme avec des combats en
fait c'est juste que les troupes russes
lettons foreuses sont changés donc
partis savent été annoncée par lavrov
qui avait dit que les objectifs
militaires avaient été atteints c'est
faux en réalité mais en fait ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que pendant tout
l'acte 1 1 il y avait cinq des huit
armées russes engagés dans l'opération
militaire spéciale comme ils disent à
moscou cinq sur huit étaient sur le
front du nord là où donc quand les
russes maintenant disent que c'était une
opération de diversion pour fixer des
troupes ukrainienne
dans le nord est comme ça elle venait
pas dans le combat ce nom on n'en voit
pas la majorité de ses troupes sur une
diversion mais est donc toutes ses
troupes se sont désengagés ils avaient
été engagées notamment depuis la
biélorussie au nord et donc elles ont
été
redéployés dans l'est de l'ukraine là où
les combats ont lieu mais ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que l'on peut pas rapatrier
des soldats les bouger des dizaines de
milliers de soldats du jour au lendemain
et par ailleurs il avait été épuisée par
des semaines de combats qui en plus elle
était partie en sanglant donc ce
redéploiement vers l'est
il fallait plusieurs semaines pour
qu'ils se mettent vraiment en place
sachant que ce retrait déploiement des
forces russes dans l'est est la même
chose qui se passe du côté ukrainien
avec les ukrainiens aussi ont ramené des
forces qui étaient au nord les ramène
vers le nom basse donc on est 200 de
concentration du de la guerre dans l'est
mais encore une fois ça veut pas dire
que la guerre est moins intense
qu'auparavant je salue gillett qui vient
de nous qui viennent nous rejoindre dans
les commentaires vous n'hésitez pas en
tout cas poser vos questions on va faire
un peu le tour de du pays pour voir
comment ça se passe dans les différents
endroits pas simple on peut on voit ces
jeunes bleus et on voit l'intersection
entre la zone bleue la zone rouge c'est
la ville de kharkiv est la ville de
kharkiv qui a fortement été bombardées
au début c'est qu'en est il maintenant
alors qu'arrive c'est la deuxième ville
de l'ukraine c'est un million et demi
d'habitants c'est absolument énorme
c'est une ville qui est plutôt
russophone traditionnellement qui
pourtant n'a pas du tout accueilli les
russes à bras ouverts ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les russes n'ont cette
invasion générale de l'ukraine très
rapidement ils se sont retrouvés coincés
enlisé cirque il faisait face à des
guerres de siège devant un très grand
nombre de villes évidemment kiev de
minimum 2 8 millions d'habitants kharkiv
me cite cherniff soumis etc et donc il
ne pouvait plus avancer donc ils sont
dix sept guerres de siège on va
s'enliser ça ne sert à rien il faut
qu'on retrouve des capacités de
manoeuvre et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
concentrent
dans l'est où là on va dire c'est de
nouveau un combat de manoeuvre qui n'est
plus un combat urbain même si on va le
rappeler le nom bas c'est une ville
aussi urbanisé lancer des plus petites
villes on ne connaît pas encore très
bien voilà les dépêches sont donc il ya
un certain nombre de noms de villes
qu'on commence à connaître mais c'est
des villes plus petites effectivement
donc kharkiv isu et il ya vraiment une
concentration peut-être qu'on peut se
dire que la la russie sccc dit au début
qu'il pouvait attaquer partout en même
temps et qu'au final ça n'a pas été le
cas il faut maintenant ce rose se
recentre et bien sûr au fait pour
produire les choses très simplement au
début le 24 février en l'opération est
lancée tous les analystes enfin tous les
commentateurs se disent on est dans un
jeu dans le cadre d'un conflit
asymétrique c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
un géant russe l'armée russe ne l'est
plus grande armée au monde
donc c'était david contre goliath les
ukrainiens qu'ils étaient en infériorité
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
différente puisque on a un une guerre
qui se joue cette fois ci avec défense
relativement symétrique alors l'une des
raisons pour ça c'est que la russie
officiellement n'est pas en guerre donc
elle n'a pas sonné la mobilisation
générale donc c'est toujours des larmes
et de contractuels
et non pas d'appeler est donc en fait
les forces engagées par la russie en
ukraine ne sont pas colossal on parle de
150000 à 200000 hommes c'est
relativement peu encore une fois pour
envahir un pays de 40 millions
d'habitants qui est plus grand que la
france
al'inverse les ukrainiens eux ils sont
en guerre ils ont été envahi et donc et
lynch qui a sonné la mobilisation
générale et donc il ya une une masse en
termes d'hommes
qui est paradoxalement le vivier est
plus grand du côté russe si les russes
changer dimension est aussi se mettaient
à mobiliser leur population mais ce qui
posait des problèmes politiques en
russie oui parce que pour l'instant il
donc là on est dans un conflit
relativement symétrique et c'est ça la
nouveauté de ces dernières semaines ces
gens que l'on prie faut le rappeler
aussi dans le dans le combat dans le
disque dans le donbass il y avait une
guerre de 2014 il ya une mine de front
les les les forces russes ont elles sont
arrivées c'est très compliqué parce que
c'était un endroit où il y avait
justement des grossistes qui est ce qui
t d qui était déjà en place ça c'est
intéressant dans les premières semaines
du conflit il y avait très peu de combat
sur la ligne de front nous voyons en
fait le candidat le dombass et de the
blast et à deux régions administratives
de donetsk est lougansk est et donc
avait une ligne de front à l'intérieur
d'une base parce qu'en 2014 les
séparatistes pro russes n'avaient pas
pris d'où le nom bath et donc cette
ligne de front a évidemment depuis
depuis 2014 les ukrainiens vraiment
avaient fortifié cette ligne de front et
donc les russes de manière assez logique
d'un point de vue militaire non non non
pas attaquer cette ligne ça aurait été
beaucoup plus difficile est par ailleurs
les ukrainiens ça depuis le début du
conflit avait fixé dans le donbass une
grande partie de leurs forces on parle
de 40 à 60% des forces ukrainienne dans
leur ensemble qui sont déployés dans le
donbass est donc là tout l'enjeu c'est
pour ça qu'on parle aujourd'hui du
dombass potentiellement comme d'une
bataille décisive tiens une bataille qui
peut définir le cours de la guerre et
pas seulement une bataille comme on a
d'autres dans les commentaires à ua qui
a eu à kindi on dit kharkov en français
car qu'y faire cov alors à nos
intentions
donc on dit car que l'on dit kharkiv en
ukrainien on dit kharkov en russe de
même qu'on dit le vif en ukrainien
le veuf en russe
nicolay f
en ukrainien etc etc
il ya aujourd'hui une sorte de
convention qui veut qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui plus tôt les noms de villes
ukrainien dans les médias français avec
peut-être une exception pour kiev parce
que kiev tout le monde connaît ce nom et
kiffe les les gens peut-être qu'on
prendrait un peu moins voilà
effectivement aller c'est pas très
logique il faut l'avouer ces particules
donc voici pour la pour la réponse pour
un usage en profitent aussi neurones qui
nous dit poutine a annoncé faire payer
le gazole bon en roubles et ça a des
conséquences on en parlera un peu plus
tard sur cet aspect sanctions censure
économique qui va avoir de réelles
répercussions pour l'europe peut-être
continuer sur cette sur cette zone d'une
base aujourd'hui dans le combat ce link
il est flexible et les forces russes est
ce qu'elle progresse est ce que les
choses bougent dans sept régions de
l'ukraine oui les forces heureuse
progresse
lentement mais elle progresse finalement
le fait qu'elle progresse lentement sait
aussi que les russes n'ont pas forcément
envie de reproduire les mêmes erreurs
qu'au début du conflit parce qu'au début
du conflit je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais les russes avaient quand
même avancé au tout début très
rapidement et il avait des lignes de
front qui sait tirer des lignes de
ravitaillement qui s'étirait parfois sur
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres ce qui
est très difficile à gérer sur un aussi
vaste espace là c'est plus concentré
comme espace donc les lignes de
ravitaillement sont ils font plus
attention de les défendre parce qu'il y
avait des avait des capacités de
d'accidents ukrainienne en arrière de la
ligne de front qui affaiblissent et
notamment les russes donc là les russes
font plus attention et comme ce que je
vous disais là on le voit pas forcément
très bien mais tout le dombass c'est une
zone
assez urbaniser en fait pour dire les
choses de manière schématique il ya deux
chapelets de ville je sais pas si vous
voyez on va dire au nord du nom basse il
ya une ville que c'est vers donesk voilà
c'est là où je mets ma souris pour ce
numéro note est donc là en fait il ya
ces verrous d'hoeness mais il ya
d'autres villes il yal'idée chance qu'il
ya ruby sinn en fait ces villes sont
collées les unes aux autres et donc ça
fait une sorte de chape les urbains et
la ligne de front et est vraiment à ce
niveau là donc là il ya des conflits
pour le coup urbain et c'est pour ça que
les re si vous voulez essaye de passer à
la fois par au dessus et par en dessous
dans un mouvement de tenaille et les
l'idée en fait de la manoeuvre russe
c'est ce et d'enveloppés les forces du
craignait pour les coincer dans cette
idée là les ukrainiens soit vont se
retrouver encerclés soit un moment
devront reculer vers l'ouest de
l'ukraine alors on n'en est pas là parce
que c'est une manoeuvre d'encerclement
et quand même assez vaste on va dire on
dessine un gros carré de 200 150
kilomètres de côtes et donc ça n'est pas
rien et donc elle ce premier chapelet de
ville vraiment le plus à l'est et vous
voyez au milieu il ya la vie de cramât
tusk ça c'est une très grande ville
depuis 2014 c'est la capitale régionale
de l'eau glace l'ukrainien de dounia
pourquoi parce que l'ancienne capitale
c'était la ville de données est et elle
est aux mains des séparatistes et donc
s'ils voulaient le coeur ukrainien du
nom basse aujourd'hui ses cravates offre
donc l'objectif final des russes re ça
sera la bataille du créateur et donc ils
attaquent par le nord par yom qui a été
une vision précise ville le 1er avril et
c'était un moment assez important et
aussi par le succès pour ça que les
forces russes viennent aussi de crimes
et si le front du sud et non pas le
front de l'est et donc à cette large
manoeuvre développement mais encore une
fois les combats avance lentement et les
russes en fait ont compris que les les
ukrainiens étaient très agile
tactiquement parce qu'ils sont très
volontaires qui sont très bien armée
avec aussi des armes occidentales très
bien renseignés tous les satellites
américains qui sont braqués sur
l'ukraine ait des avions qui sont pas
très loin il donne des données tactiques
aux ukrainiens et donc là les russes se
disent mais on n'a pas envie que nos
colonnes de chars se fasse
détruire par les missiles antichars
occidentaux par l'artillerie ukrainienne
est donc en fait les russes en
reviennent une vieille stratégie
soviétique c'est yvon bardes une fois
qu'il est dans ton bouton bombardé il
avance avec les chars mais c'est pas le
seul blessé pas les chars qui avancent
en premier et qui vont au choc qui dicte
le tempo quelque part et et du coup on
le comprend c'est une stratégie qui
prend du temps on n'est pas sur une
rapide qui prend du temps parce que on
va en parler là en c'est une guerre pour
être très longue et donc l'une des
questions c'est la question de
l'attrition alors la pression c'est tout
simplement à vos cours d'une guerre
chaque camp perdre et fort ce que ça
soit des forces humaines ou du matériel
et au bout d'un moment il ya un point en
dessous duquel ben l'un des deux
belligérants
peut plus faire la guerre et donc 7 en
fait l'une des questions c'est en terme
de pression est ce que les russes
peuvent tenir longtemps que les
ukrainiens ou inversement et donc les
russes ont perdu beaucoup d'hommes et
beaucoup de matériel pendant l'acte 1
dont on a parlé notamment autour de kiev
qui a été un désastre militaire premier
russe viennent probablement a envie de
faire la même chose dont le nom bath et
donc ils privilégient d'abord les
phrases d'artillerie pour aggraver
l'attrition ukrainienne sans encombre en
minimisant leurs propres affaires je
pense que c'est ça un peu le le rapport
de force alors on a trublion dans les
commentaires qui nous remercient pour
cela qui explique clairement la
situation loin des propagandes russe
neurones qui me dit merci le figaro
merci à vous en tout cas certain d'être
présent et vous n'hésitez pas bien
évidemment à poser vos questions par
exemple là j'en vois une de bénac said
et qui nous dit est ce que la france est
en guerre contre la russie avec ses
livraisons d'armes c'est une question
qu'on a depuis le début de ses live
depuis de nombreux domaines depuis le 24
février en question et les occidentaux a
été très clair sur cette question ils ne
veulent pas franchir la ligne rouge de
l'aco belligérants cirque il n'est pas
question que la france les états unis le
royaume uni soit en guerre avec la
russie à partir de la sinne c'est un
rapport de force parce qu'il faut être 2
quand même pour déclarer la guerre et
donc il faut les les occidentaux font
tout pour soutenir les ukrainiens y
compris en armes et aujourd'hui mon arme
lourde mais en restant en deçà du seuil
au dessus duquel il y aurait de facto un
état de guerre entre les occidentaux
et la russie et c'est pour ça qu'ils le
sang de 2
de d'electric dans le langage des russes
et des occidentaux poutine très
régulièrement dit attention vous n'allez
pas plus loin parce que sinon voilà
c'est une sorte de menace et donc c'est
un jeu oratoire entre entre les deux
camps donc on est dans le camp ukrainien
mais n'est pas en guerre avec la russie
mais on parle alors aussi de l'arme
nucléaire qui est agité par apa par
vladimir poutine on a une question très
intéressante de 2,2 à ua qui nous dit la
russie se passe-t-elle toujours de
couverture aérienne on a vu au début du
conflit que à vouloir progresser sans
contrôler le ciel c'était dangereux pour
eux bien sûr alors c'était aussi une des
grandes surprises de cette guerre on
pensait vraiment que les russes allaient
avoir le contrôle du ciel ukrainien sans
la moindre difficulté l'armée de l'air
russe est incomparablement
grande en nombre d'avions que celles de
l'ukraine et aussi en termes qualitatifs
cirque en fait les avions ukrainien
c'est des vieux mig 29 d'origine
soviétique ont pas été modernisé il ya
quelques et 27 cd des vieux avions et
les russes en revanche depuis le début
des années 2010 ont quand même conduit
une réforme qui font qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont des avions qui ceux qui ont les
mêmes origines que les ukrainiennes mais
qui scellait des versions modernisées
des sukhoi 30 des sukhoi 30 5 etc et là
on a vu que les en termes d'engagement
des forces aériennes la russie est
extrêmement timorés et que de facto
elles ne contrôlaient pas le ciel
ukrainien avec un certain nombre
d'aéronefs qu'ont été détruits par les
ukrainiens grâce notamment aux aux
missiles anti aériens qui leur ont été
livrés par les par les puissances
occidentales notamment les fameux
stinger convié déjà dans la guerre
d'afghanistan
donc à la fois des hélicoptères des
avions et donc le résultat est bien
c'est que physiquement il ne contrôle
pas le ciel aérien
alors il ya néanmoins un petit
changement dans le nom bassir que là où
il y avait un usage vraiment faible de
l'aviation on voit que déjà dans le
donbass il utilise beaucoup plus
l'aviation auparavant donc ça pourrait
suggérer
les russes sont un peu plus à l'aise
dans leurs manoeuvres dans ce front de
l'est auparavant dans la vision générale
de l'ukraine autre point puisqu'on
parlait de l'aviation on a vu l'emploi
de bombardier dont ils peuvent par
définition emporté beaucoup plus de
bombes
dd tu peux l'efs convoler notamment vers
marioupol donc ça l'engagement de
bombardier tactique
c'est un nouveau seuil qui est franchie
ils ont monté les bombardiers par
définition soit assez vulnérable comme
avions plus que des chasseurs donc s'ils
les envoient aussi les déploie encore
une fois ça montre qu'ils sont un peu
plus en confiance en tout cas à cet
endroit là de l'ukraine auparavant à une
question d'alain théâtre qui nous dit
d'où sortent les pilotes ukrainiens
alors au sans répondre exactement à
cette occasion mais surtout il faut
rappeler quelque chose c'est que
l'ukraine et et en paix et en guerre
déjà depuis un moment dans le donetsk
dans le donbass et du coup son armée
a eu besoin de ceux de se moderniser de
se mobiliser il paraît qu'il ya une
vraie habitude de ce côté là alors sur
cette question là donc les avions
ukrainiens sont vraiment pas moderne du
tout c'est un des vieux coucous mai mais
en revanche les pilotes quand même
ukrainiens ont été ont su bien d
entraînement assez intensive depuis 2014
et donc paradoxalement ce sont peut-être
mieux entraînés que les russes et
notamment ils ont été entraînés
par l'otan il ya eu des exercices
communs entre les puissances de l'otan
et l'armée de l'air et ukrainienne donc
ils sont probablement mieux préparés que
les russes on sait que le des faiblesses
de l'armée russe sait qu'en nombre
d'heures de vol les russes veulent peut
donc s'ils veulent peu et bien le jour
il faut vraiment partir à la guerre ils
n'ont pas forcément les les les réflexes
et le la formation pour mener à bien
leur mission une question d'échelle mais
on va pas pouvoir lui répondre
précisément bien évidemment c est ce que
l'ukraine est ce que les ukrainiens vont
gagner la guerre ça ça on ne peut pas
vous répondre mais par contre il ya ya
ya ya rapport de m déjà la question se
pose oui ce qui est intéressant alors
qu'il ya de moins en moins 24 février à
sanaa ils croyaient une personne n'y
croyait objectivement je aucun analyste
là aujourd'hui la question de pose donc
ça dit quelque chose a effectivement du
rapport de force entre les deux
belligérants
on a toujours ce foyer on m'a dit qu'ils
nous demandent les pilotes ukrainiens
combien sont ils à ce combat s alors je
serai capable de répondre à ces
questions voilà mais on doit vous un
chiffre on doit on doit voir ces
chiffres là mais nous ne savons pas tout
bien évidemment mais vous continuez à
poser vos questions comment comme on
vous le dit on essaye d'y répondre du
mieux que l'on peut donc on n'a pas
parlé du nom basse on peut parler du sud
du pays maintenant le sud on rappelle
alors juste un point oui pour répondre
aux mêmes candidats dif on sait en
revanche qu'il ya le nombre d'aéronefs
ukrainiens se comptent en quelques
dizaines donc ça donne un dans de
grandes heures très bien on veut parler
maintenant du du sud du pays le sud du
pays on rappelle la crimée qui a été
annexé par là par la russie et les
forces russes y ont progressé très
rapidement et qui ensuite ont été elles
ont progressé rapidement elles ont été
bloquées et depuis on est sur un sur un
blocage de et des lignes de front il ya
une forme d'une mobilisation des forces
avec quelques nuances malgré tout mais
peut-être puisqu'on parle de sud
commencer par mario est bien terrien et
sexy c'est un peu le effectivement entre
eux puisque c'est encore géographique
lancer dans le donbass
c'est dans le blast 2 de miettes donc
c'est le le port stratégique de la mer
d'azov le dombass est une région très
industrielle s'est historiquement
historiquement l'une des régions les
plus riches de l'ue créé mais c'était
historiquement alors c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya une
désindustrialisation massive qui ne
remonte pas 2014 qui ont étaient
antérieurs mais voilà marioupol c'était
un port important et donc s'ils
voulaient pour les russes contrôlées les
bords de la mer d'azov c'était un
objectif
certains on a pas de doute là-dessus
d'autant que ça leur permet de voiliers
de de créer un corridor terrestre avec
la crimée qui sans cela n'est pas relié
au territoire russe sauf par le pont de
kertch à l'entrée de la mer d'azov
qu'une mère quasi fermé donc voilà
marioupol c'est très important
ça a été une bataille
très très violente c'est une ville de
quatre millions d'habitants donc c'est
pas une petite ville et surtout les
ukrainiens étaient très bien préparées
défendu il savait très bien qu'en cas de
guerre c'est un objectif
numéro un du kremlin et donc notamment à
marioupol vous aviez à la fois l'armée
ukrainienne et fait partie de l'armée
ukrainienne mais les fameux bataillon
azoff qui sont des bataillons ultra
nationaliste avec des origines néonazis
un peu un peu trouble même si une
politique va dire de dénazification
menée par l'ukraine depuis 2014 et donc
là on est vraiment au coeur de la
bataille idéologique de guerre de
propagande entre la russie et l'ukraine
évidemment pour la russie battre le
bataillon azoff à marioupol c'est c'est
un enjeu vital d'une certaine manière si
les russes battent azoff à marioupol ils
pourront dire que l'un de leurs
objectifs
premiers qui étaient la dénazification
se rate alors c'est facile puisque comme
on sait pas très bien ce qu'il ya
derrière la notion de dénazification
c'est facile de dire que l'objectif est
atteint mais malgré tout pour la date du
9 mai donc elle à la grande fête en
russie pour célébrer la victoire lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale contre contre
les nazis il faut que poutine puisse
dire on a conquis marivaux reconquis
mari mme paul et on a battu azoff oui
parce que jusque là il n'y a pas
forcément de victoire russe et pépé
eye-fi pm de la seule grande vie la
seule capitale régionale tenue par les
russes actuellement ces personnes et à
l'embouchure du nieppe
c'est la seule grande ville a repris ya
plein d'autres villes qui le contrôle
mais parmi les grandes villes il ya que
carson alors marioupol aujourd'hui toute
la ville est tenu par les airs par les
russes mais dans la vie il ya une zone
de vide dans la ville qu'est le grand
complexe si des
métallurgistes des apps talent alors
c'est vraiment gigantesque c'est sur des
kilomètres carrés à la fois en 2d au
niveau du sol et puis par ailleurs il ya
des il ya plusieurs niveaux il ya
plusieurs niveaux il ya des tunnels mais
qui datent pas de 2014
mais très en profondeur
donc c'est une sorte de dédales et donc
là il y aurait encore la dernière
destination c'était entre 1000 et 2000
combattants d'azov quelques bâtons
l'armée régulière ukrainienne et puis
quelques civils quelques centaines de
civils et là c'est intéressant la
semaine dernière
au départ on s'était lancé tiba les
russes vont achever de prendre cette
ville il veut rentrer dans le complexe
des neuf stades et ils vont voir ans a
fini de marioupol ils ont choisi une
autre solution qui est de faire le siège
des apps talent poutine a utilisé cette
formule il faut pas qu'une mouche pu
sortir de la zac stahl est donc
maintenant ils attendent alors
militairement c'est pas absurde
pourquoi parce que dans ces logis dans
ces guerres vraiment urbaine de
la vente âge est vraiment en défense et
il faut un je sais plus quel sort et
quels sont les chiffres en tactique
militaire mais pour point défenseur il
faut 10 10 attaquants quasiment et c'est
encore plus vrai asos talent du fait de
la défaite des souterrains et donc la
poutine qu'un problème d'attrition que
de ses forces comme le commanditaire n'a
aucune envie de perdre des milliers de
soldats russes
à marioupol lui préfère reprendre ses
forces de marie paule et les redéployer
ailleurs dans le donbass pour la grande
bataille du no mas est donc là il a
décidé de garder déchets quelques
bataillons pour tenir sociale daps
talent attendre une reddition et qui
pourrait prendre des semaines et
potentiellement des mois il ya des
réserves de nourriture et des réserves
d'eau etc
mais donc militairement ça fait sens
même si ça montre les limites de l'art
merlus en termes d'hommes et puis ça
empêche ce côté grand foutoir de marie
politiquement
le 9 mai peut-être que poutine pourra
pas dire on contrôle absolument
marie-paule ils contrôleront marioupol à
l'exception des apps talent où il ya
encore des le bataillon azoff kiki
ce sont des héros fait
le court et ses héroïnes de faire ça et
donc pour le camp ukrainien ils pourront
dire regardez ces héros ils tiennent
jusqu'au bout ne seront pas on à cédric
qui nous demandaient ce que les
ukrainiens ont des tentes il détruit
leurs ports de marie-paule lors on
disait marie paule et comme un apport
très important pour l'ukraine les phares
les russes ont l'homme embardée aussi il
est complètement détruit et plus du tout
utilisable
on a quand même vu que les russes ont
réussi à récupérer quelques petit
patrouilleurs des petits bateaux armés
de deux canons donc visiblement les
ukrainiens n'ont pas saborder leur
flottille alors qu'il avait fait par
exemple
à nikolaïev il avait coulé leur seul
frégates
était pas en service qu on travaux ils
ont coulé mais marion peut l'entendre or
la ville est très largement
détruite alors on a des questions aussi
sur les alors vous avez beaucoup de
questions j'ai un peu du mal à tout
reprendre ne vous inquiétez pas mais on
parlera de tous les sujets que vous
abordez c'est promis on parle pas au
delà de la marine russe est ce que est
ce que la marine russe on le sait qu'il
a perdu son son vaisseau amiral alors
suite à un incident selon
selon les russes mais maintenant un
incident on va dire vire militaire assez
provoqué voilà on peut le dire est ce
qu'il n'ya plus tellement de doutes sur
le fait que c'était une frappe de deux
missiles antinavires neptune
d'ukrainiens qui est un dérivé
moderniser d'un an
missiles russes
[Musique]
lujan
mais ses traits ce qui s'est passé est
très intéressant le la perte du mobile
va c'est une très grande perte
symbolique c'est une très grande perte
politique c'est une humiliation
militairement
c'est un navire qui avait été mis en
service en 1982 vous faites le calcul
c'était quand même un vieux navire qui
d'après tous les spécialistes devaient
pas rester en service encore très
longtemps et qui ne jouait pas un rôle
déterminant dans la guerre en ukraine
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'il
lui il était chargé de historiquement de
la lutte antinavire c'est un tueur de
porte avions donc il n'y avait pas de
frappe de
domicile
en ukraine depuis une mesure va il avait
un os drôle c'était la lutte
antiaérienne y avait des missiles s 300
f à bord mais en fait c'étaient des
vieux missiles qui n'avait pas été
modernisées donc en termes de lutte
antiaérienne à à longue distance les
russes avait d'autres moyens que le mot
sous va donc ces pros n'ont pas l'enjeu
essentiel l'enjeu essentiel c'est que
les russes ont réalisé tout d'un coup il
ne contrôlait pas la mer noire et en
fait depuis le dessin vous pouvez tracer
un
[Musique]
cercle enfin un arc de cercle on va dire
de 102 200 km voire 300 qui est là
qu'elle a apportée en fait des missiles
neptune ukrainien et bien c'est en fait
c'est une zone qui tout le nord de la
mer noire où les russes et bas auront
énormément de mal à naviguer et si on
trace ce trait sur 300 km en fait on est
quasiment aux portes de sébastopol donc
pour les russes c'est un enjeu
stratégique énorme il n'arrêtait pas de
râler sur le fait que l'otan à odessa
souhaité une menace existentielle pour
la russie alors qu'ils n'étaient pour
une fois pas question en tout cas à
court ou moyen termes d'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan mais là tout d'un
coup c'est une menace très réelle que
les russes avaient complètement
sous-estimé il ne croyait pas que ces
médecines neptune qui avait été mise en
service il ya deux ans était vraiment
une menace pour l'armée russe là il
réalise que c'est le cas et ça c'est un
énorme bouleversement
stratégique pour la russie sachant que
en termes il est clair les missiles
neptunia une fois il faut un missile en
fait il faut pouvoir identifier une
cible et pour pouvoir l'engager et là il
est très clair que les renseignements
occidentaux ont probablement joué très
lourd dans la capacité des ukrainiens
justement à faire ce travail de
renseignement ensuite identifier des
cibles et ça c'est une vraie menace pour
l'armée russe et ça les conforte
peut-être dans l'idée qu'il faudra non
seulement ils contrôlent les bords de la
mer d'azov mais aussi les bords de la
mer noire et c'est à dire qu'ils aillent
jusqu'à odessa alors encore une fois et
d'ailleurs il ya un général russe alors
un grand général non c'est pas une
à une grande annonce officiellement fin
ils l'ont dit quand même que l'objectif
de l'opération militaire spéciale
dorénavant c'était le contrôle de tout
le sud de l'ukraine du dombass
jusqu'à la transnistrie dont on parlera
peut-être après mais c'est pas anodin
évidemment qu à valognes dans les
commentaires qui me dit bonjour le fait
que l'europe livre des armes lourdes à
l'ukraine et que la russie viennent de
mettre en garde cela ne compte pas une
guerre avec d'autres pays donc on parle
d'ailleurs de convergence et pourquoi ce
changement soudain de l'europe la
livraison d'armes il ne fait selon lui
qu'aggraver le couvent
alors il ya une raison militaire c'est
que justement dans cet acte 2
cd combat vraiment de manoeuvre
armée contre armée avec un usage
intensif de l'artillerie et donc les
ukrainiens pour résister des missiles
antichars portatif à l'épaule ont pas d
très grande portée ça suffit pas pour
arrêter le rouleau compresseur russie
donc ils ont besoin concrètement
notamment de moyens d'artillerie avec
une portée suffisante pour pouvoir
frapper
les
les dispositifs d'artillerie adverse de
la russie et notamment on a vu que la
france ça c'est officiel et un
changement dans la doctrine française
qui maintenant disent qu'elle envoie la
france a envoyé des canons caesar
qui ont une portée je peux dire des
bêtises mais dans mon souvenir c'est 40
50 km supérieur à la plupart des
obusiers russe et donc ça c'est
probablement pas anecdotique on a vu que
deux pays notamment les états unis vont
envoyer des des obusiers sa décret bien
la réalité la guerre d'ukraine
aujourd'hui c'est une guerre où
l'artillerie est vraiment la pièce
maîtresse du dispositif russe et il faut
que ça soit le cas aussi du dispositif
ukrainien s'ils veulent résister oui
pour qui et pour qui une symétrie on a
eu à dans l'est dans les commentaires
qui nous parle de la est ce que les
russes ont pris le contrôle de la vie de
nikolaïev donc nikolaïev à ce que ces
mines non non non alors mais c'est
nicolas ivanoff à nikolaïev
c'est peut-être le l'occasion de parler
de ce qui se passe au sud de oui oui
fait un point général pour le gall on a
l'impression que cette cei c'est cette
ligne de front alors comment l'elysée
elle a avancé très rapidement et depuis
c'est stabilisé et elle n'a pas beaucoup
avancé le coup c'est une région qui peut
habiter quand on regarde le nombre
d'habitants par oblast le blast de
carson le bleis de 2 à porridge ya plus
à l'est ce sont deux petits oblath
ukrainien met donc les russes ont avancé
très vite au début pendant l'acte no 1
est tout simplement ils se sont
retrouvés avec le problème dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure c'est un manque
d'hommes pour aller plus loin et donc on
s'est dit on avait atteint un point
culminant du conflit c'est à dire qu'à
partir d'un certain seuil est bien l'un
des deux co belligérants n'a plus
suffisamment de forces pour continuer
d'avancer et donc les russes étaient
stabilisés vous voyez autour de carson à
l'ouest ils ont réussi à franchir le n'y
être il grand fleuve qui traverse
l'ukraine du nord au sud et ça ils s'y
tiennent ils veulent vraiment rester à
carson c'est leur grande ville donc ça
serait une perte symbolique terrible et
surtout il veut ni veulent toujours
avoir un pied
dans de l'autre côté d'unia prg mais là
pour les russes maintenant l'objectif
c'est principalement de se fortifier
c'est à dire que nul ne puisse pas y
avoir de grandes contre-offensive
ukrainienne dont sur le front du sud
nous d'ailleurs ils ont il ya un certain
nombre de dar mais qui étaient déployés
au nord qui n'ont pas été envoyés dans
le donbass mais dans le sud donc ça
montre bien l'intérêt de la russie pour
cette large bande de territoire qui va
de l'est de la mer noire toute la mer
d'azov maintenant ils n'ont pas à ce
stade suffisamment de forces pour aller
tellement plus loin
sur ce fond du sud sachons que ces
dernières semaines vous voyez on le voit
d'ailleurs les petits points bleus l'un
il ya eu quelques contre attaques
ukrainienne j'ai parle bien de contre
attaque tactique et pas d'une contre
offensive générale général stratégique
les contre attaques ukrainiennes n'ont
pas porté leurs fruits et alors chaque
jour sachant dire que les ukrainiens
attaque puis les russes reprennent donc
ça bouge pas énormément on voit malgré
tout les russes qui essaye d'avancer
le long d'une ligne app mais à l'ouest
là où il ya les l'espèce des toiles qui
montre les combats vers kryviy rih alors
ces points n'ont pas une grande
offensive parce qu'encore une fois ils
ont pas les moyens de la faire et
problement pour fixer des troupes
ukrainienne tant que toutes les troupes
ukrainienne n'aille pas dans le combat
ce n'est par ailleurs ça peut dire
quelque chose des objectifs non pas à
court terme mais plutôt à moyen terme de
la russie sais pas si vous voyez donc on
remonte le nia près puis à la grande
ville de happo reejer
ça ça peut être un objectif
de moyen terme pour la russie mais qui
va être complètement déterminé par le
sort de la bataille du no mas si les
russes ne gagne pas de manière décisive
et un prix supportable
cette bataille il sera évidemment hors
de question qu'ils après déjà une
conditionnalité il ya un effet domino on
prend une trentaine d'hommes déploie pas
tout faire en même temps comme il
l'avait fait au début de l'invasion mais
donc ça pourrait déjà ça pourrait être
un objectif de moyen terme et on voit
qu'ils auraient tout intérêt à passer à
la fois par l'ouest via donc cette ville
de kryviy rih et par l'est avec le fond
du débat ce qui aurait avancé voilà mais
c'est encore et puis après on peut
imaginer qu'ils aillent jusqu'à dnipro
mais on n'en est vraiment pas là encore
une fois on fait bien comprendre qu'on
parle en combat rien que la bataille du
nom base c'est à minima des semaines et
des semaines il avance de 1 2 km par
jour le temps de tout faire on parle
aussi de la difficulté de tenir les
villes kherson vit une grave et
l'ukrainienne qui l'est qu'ils
contrôlent à cet excès qui nous
demandent comment ça va se passer si les
les habitants sont recrutés par l'armée
russe alors c'est on a commencé à voir
sap a été confirmé quelques sources dans
les médias russes sur les réseaux
sociaux russes parlant d'une
mobilisation générale
à kherson dans la partie douze appareils
déjà contrôlé par les russes
donc une mobilisation générale comme
celle qui avait eu à donetsk ou à wall
ou blanches je suis pas sûr que les
habitants soient très content et
haïssent se battre avec la fleur au
fusil c'est une possibilité pour
l'instant qui est qui et pas confirmé en
revanche ce qui est assez clair c'est
qu'on voit pas pour l'instant de de
comment on pourrait appeler ça de
d'insurrection dans les villes
contrôlées par les russes de la
population ukrainienne contre l'occupant
il ya des manifestations depuis le début
il ya des manifestations notamment à
carson enfin pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de guérilla
tout cas visible ou massive qui se met
en place dans les territoires contrôlés
donc ça c'est plutôt entre guillemets
une bonne nouvelle pour les russes parce
que si en plus il avait à gérer guérilla
au singulier rien dire il ya un
intérieur des territoires occupés pour
eux ça sera encore une difficulté
supplémentaire alors on avait pas mal de
questions va continuer à se déplacer en
direction de l'ouest donc la ville
d'odessa par exemple mais il ya aussi un
pays frontaliers la moldavie avec la
transnistrie alors on avait beaucoup de
questions alors je les aide les jeunes
et plus vos pseudos ce qu'il avait posée
mais la lame la moldavie transnistrie
est ce que
les russes qui contrôle une partie de
2,7 de ce pays est ce qu'il peut y avoir
quelque chose qui se passe de ce côté-là
faut remonter en arrière dont 80
dislocation de l'union soviétique
la moldavie déclare son indépendance et
en fait vous avez une bande de terre à
l'est de la moldavie
vous le montrer sur la carte voilà
l'instant c'est vraiment une bande de
terre n'est pas large la moldavie étant
ici alors la roumanie moldavie étant là
et cette petite bande de terre et vous
et le 1-1 en rouge c'est c'est la
transnistrie que c'est la transnistrie
donc c'est une population russophone et
russophile et qui pour le coup en 91 a
pris sa quasi indépendants sont très
très grande autonomie
et donc des 91 les russes sont déployés
en transnistrie
désamorce pas énorme mais c'est 1500 à
2000 soldats et depuis c'est une sorte
de conflit larvé enfin il n'y a plus de
combats depuis très longtemps s'est
stabilisé mais malgré tout alors
officiellement évidemment la
transnistrie fait toujours partie de la
de la moldavie mais on imagine bien
l'objectif
potentiel de la russie s'il arrive à
contrôler tout le sud de l'ukraine c'est
qu'ils arrivent jusqu en transnistrie et
donc là potentiellement en termes de
droit international
la crainte qu'on peut avoir c'est que le
conflit s'élargissent à un autre pays
que l'ukraine qui serait la moldavie
sachant que la moldavie qui évidemment
alors est toujours eu des relations
ambiguës avec la russie elle a toujours
elle n'a jamais essayé de montée aux
extrêmes a toujours essayé négocier
prudemment avec la russie mais là elle
se tourne vers l'ouest de manière assez
notable et notamment les choses se sont
accélérées quand jean yves le drian en
mars si je m'abuse est allé en moldavie
était le jour où la présidente moldave a
annoncé elle avait déposé officiellement
son acte de candidature de la moldavie à
l'union européenne
donc voyez c'est très avec extrêmement
politique et donc ces derniers jours ce
qu'on a vu c'est des explosions en
transnistrie
on s'est pas qui à l'origine de ces
explosions une explosion par exemple
dans la tour radio
mais on voit bien ça pourrait être en
tout cas les ukrainiens de craignent une
attaque ce qu'on appelle sous faux
drapeau c'est les russes auraient fait
sauter eux mêmes
une tour nos radios en transnistrie pour
dire regardez ils nous attaquent ils ou
elles avaient la rage nous protégeons
les populations russophones et donc ça
nous donne une entre guillemets
légitimité pour pousser l'opération
militaire spéciale jusqu en transnistrie
est-ce que c'était ce que cela pourrait
provoquer une escalade des tensions
puisque le conflit s'étendrait vers un
nouveau pays après le guen la moldavie
et ça pourrait cesser un risque alors
après là où il faut rester prudent
et ne pas
catastrophiste entre guillemets on l'a
dit on l'a redit à rennes pour le
dombass et des semaines donc les russes
militaire mort ne sont pas du tout peur
en capacité d'aller jusqu'en
transnistrie à court terme est par
ailleurs ils n'ont aucun moyen
de déployer des soldats
un autre moyen jusqu en transnistrie où
il n'y a pas de bande de terre n'y a pas
d'accès la moldavie n'a pas d'accès à la
mer
est toute manière on l'a vu avec le
moskva il n'est plus du tout question de
débarquement de troupes russes à odessa
c'est absolument impossible étant donné
le business il n'est plus non dont on
parlait justement là une question de
deux eric à votre avis pourquoi les
russes ont tenté de détruire le kung au
sud d'odessa ce qu'ils veulent débarqué
on peut pas nommer laser ils peuvent pas
débarqué c'est absolument impossible
encore une fois au début du conflit on
l'avait bien vu les probablement pour
fixer les ukrainiens d'ailleurs les
russes avaient mis au large de desa
quasiment la totalité de leur flotte de
la mer noire
en termes amphibie c'était une dizaine
de groupes nouveau bateau de
débarquement ils pouvaient débarquer en
ukraine cinq mille hommes on n'est pas
5000 hommes
prenez pas au dessin avec 5000 hommes
c'est absolument possible qu'en réalité
il peut pas y avoir de débarquement sans
opération terrestre en parallèle et sans
garantie que les que les russes
contrôlent la mer noire à cet endroit là
il ya des mines il ya des menaces de
tirs de missiles absolument impossible
en revanche pour la destruction du pont
et bien les russes continuent de taper
on va dire toutes les
les installations
logistiques vital de l'ukraine
pour affaiblir le pays notamment pour
réduire sa capacité de
deux mouvements des troupes à
l'intérieur l'ukraine donc les ponts les
noeuds ferroviaires
les capacités de construction
d'électricité des centrales électriques
mais des objectifs comme ça
effectivement alors là on nous avons
fait le tour un peu de la 2e de chaque
espace géographique et j'avais une
question qui a été posée alors le rêve
aussi mais militairement est ce qu'on
peut dire que globalement les russes en
train de reprendre l'avantagé
actuellement c'est trop tôt pour le dire
là on peut rien dire d'autre que la
bataille du nom basse est engagé on est
globalement dans un conflit relativement
symétrique et pour l'instant les russes
ont des gains sur le terrain mais
avancent lentement
fait dire tellement plu et on avait une
autre question alors je vais essayer de
retrouver d'un anonyme tu dis
existe-t-il un risque d'attaqués
nucléaires tactiques de moscou on a on
en a entendu qui n'a en reparler ccc une
menace qu'il agite depuis le début du
conflit alors on rappelle qu'une attaque
nucléaire il ya plusieurs types
d'attaqué avec clerc peut être être fait
là on parle d' attaques nucléaires
tactiques sur une ville alors en fait
redire donc les si vous voulez la
principe de dissuasion nucléaire c'est
que c'est des seuils différents
le stade ultime c'est de pays
sans voix
des bombes thermonucléaires
qui peuvent par leur puissance quasiment
détruire un pays ça c'est le niveau
ultime c'est ce qu'on appelle la
destruction mutuelle assurée c'est ce
qui fait que normalement deux puissances
nucléaires ne se font pas d'ailleurs
après il peut y avoir un parapluie
nucléaire l'allier enfin dans les états
unis protègent les autres européens
voilà ça c'est le niveau qu'on appelle
stratégique mais simplement les russes
et les américains depuis la guerre
froide se sont dits peut y avoir un
usage tactique de la bombe nucléaire
celle que là tout d'un coup la bombe
nucléaire devient une arme d'emploi
d'emploi sur le champ de bataille est
donc là bas on peut
imaginer des bons de tailles différentes
ça peut être un emploi militaire contre
des forces militaires et ça peut être
aussi un emploi contre une ville et là
on choisit la taille de la ville
et donc le risque évidemment on n'en est
pas du tout un risque de
destruction mutuelle entre les états
unis ou les grands pays européens et la
russie ont heureusement il ya une
maîtrise de l'escaladent puis à une
grammaire de la dissuasion nucléaire qui
est quand même maîtrisé par l'ensemble
des protagonistes
mais en revanche les russes
mettent en avant
cette possibilité en leurs mots sont
très choisi une sorte de flou parce
qu'on veut évidemment pas connaître les
lignes rouges les saints etc mais c'est
une inquiétude
manifeste c'est quelque chose qui
malheureusement pourrait arriver et
pourrait arriver si les notamment si les
russes perdent et complètement là la
main une cren le problème des russes
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas tellement de
moyens de pression sur les occidentaux
ils ont le nucléaire c'est traditionnel
épuisant mais ils ont l'énergie
mais entre les deux que peut faire
poutine pour infléchir les réactions des
pays occidentaux à il a pas grand chose
et donc régulièrement
il ressort un discours nucléaire
avant-hier aux avant-ventes imc un plus
il a rappelé il qui pourrait y avoir des
qualités sa phrase mais tant de
représailles massives en cas de mise en
danger des intérêts
vite au delà la russie sachant que les
intérêts vitaux il avait même en plus
dit ce n'était pas seulement les
intérêts vitaux de la russie c'est dans
le cadre de l'opération militaire
spéciale en ukraine mais c'est un peu un
constat de d'impulser en série à chaque
fois on met la pression à poutine il n'y
a pas tellement de carte à jouer lors il
sort les cartes oui c'est un
fait divers yade a condamné dix pensez
vous que l'opinion russe commence à se
douter de la vérité alors je verrai
formuler la question mais est ce que en
russie
comment est venue cette passion ne crois
pas du tout mais enfin ça dépend ce
qu'on appelle vérité mais mais bien sûr
ça c'est ce qu'on a vu au début de
l'invasion merlus était un peu fébrile
enfin c'est ce que ce convoi de faim de
gens qui sont en mousse coup on nous le
raconter
une sorte de fébrilité il comprenait pas
que très bien quels étaient les
objectifs de la russie a raison
puis se lancer dans une grande guerre
comme ça c'était
hélas qu'on voit très nettement c'est
que la russie globalement fait vraiment
bloc derrière vladimir poutine déjà il y
avait des sondages de l'institut levada
qui est un institut indépendant est la
marque de son indépendance c'est à dire
qu'il est considéré comme une agence
comme un agent de l'étranger par la
législation russe etc ont montré que la
cote de popularité de poutine a
littéralement bondi ll s'effritait
depuis 2014 elle est mon billet en 2014
c'est la grâce à un crime et un slim et
et ensuite en raison des difficultés
économiques de la russie elle s'était
érodée rodez rodez de sorte que poutine
avait une cote de popularité qui alla la
fin était descendue à un taux de 60% à
ce qui est déjà très bien pour beaucoup
de pays occidentaux qui rêveraient de
même score mais pour poutine s'était
relativement faible et là elle a
littéralement bondi dans mon souvenir le
chiffre de levada c'était 83 %
d'opinions favorables des russes
vis-à-vis de lanières poutine et 80% de
soutien à l'opération militaire spéciale
et on le voit le les russes font bloc
alors il ya plein de raisons ils des
raisons de coûts comme de propagande
c'est l'efficacité de la propagande
notamment la télévision publique dos et
puis il ya des billets plus
psychologique mais que son problème en
plus puissants on a beaucoup parlé des
mères de soldats en disant oui attention
elles pourraient ne pas supporter tous
ces cercueils qui rentre à moscou il ya
des chercheurs qui ont dit attention si
vous perdez votre fils ou combat que
vous le voyez revenir dans un cercueil
qu'est ce que vous allez dire vrai dire
mon fils est mort pour rien
non c'est inhumain c'est à dire ça alors
dans ces cas là paradoxalement on a
tendance à vouloir croire le discours
qui est servi par les autorités parce
que se dire qu'on fait une guerre pour
rien c'est insupportable très bien pour
ce poids
alors je vais essayer de prendre
certaines questions parce qu'on en a
encore pas mal mais on va devoir arrêter
slide ans quand même pas trop lourd pour
libérer alexis bien sûr puisqu'il a un
peu d'autres choses à faire aussi mais
en tout cas c'est merci de continuer à
peu continuer à poser vos questions on
va essayer d'en reprendre une par
exemple sur les sur les armes byden qui
avait acquis et qui a loué qui veut
allouer 33 milliards de dollars pour
aider l'ukraine à se défendre est ce que
ça peut changer le cours de la guerre se
seraient revendues oui on en a parlé
c'est que nous il ya un besoin d'armes
lourdes
pour s'adapter à la nature du conflit
aujourd'hui notamment dans le nombre à
l'article donc oui ça peut changer la
donne en ce sens que comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure l'issue de la guerre
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout connue
d'avancé personne ne peut le dire après
dans la rhétorique américaine est
quelque chose qui est intéressant au
débat au départ biden disait bien que
l'objectif de la fourniture des armes
c'était pour défendre l'ukraine est là
dans certaines déclarations il dit c'est
pour affaiblir la russie c'est
d'ailleurs assez intéressant que kiel
qu'ils l'avouent l'assument
c'est en tribune politique
ostensiblement
anti-lru donc ça c'est un changement de
changement de focale dans la politique
américaine
entre autres questions sur la s ur les
beaucoup de commentaires on a
effectivement sur le sur l'énergie la
russie qui a coupé le gaz à la pologne
c'est une arme diplomatique est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce que
l'europe soit complètement et du gaz
russe un peu comme pour le nucléaire
mais en les conséquences sont quand même
un peu moins grave c'est que c'est un
peu un fusil à un coup sauf vous enfin
mes jeux avec le robinet mes
larmes de poutine c'est de dire je vais
couper complètement le gaz et le pétrole
l europe mais ça aurait des conséquences
graves pour les pour l'économie russe
on a vu que pour le budget com enfin
la russie peuvent en un budget à
l'équilibré avec un
baril à 40 de la très bien donc ça sa
irai mais si jamais les russes ne
vendent plus leur pétrole et leurs gaz à
l'europe faut qu'il le vende ailleurs en
asie par exemple mais c'est pas comme
des biens de consommation courants on
peut pas fabriquer un un gazoduc
ça prend des années donc c'est de
réorienter la politique commerciale
énergétiques russes vers l'asie ça
prendrait des années et donc entre temps
ça serait extrêmement difficile
pour les russes et de supporter cela
néanmoins ce convoi et que quand même
très notable c'est que les sanctions
financières de des occidentaux contre la
russie qui était censé
mettra enfin faire s'effondrer le rouble
à sanaa là cet endroit là ça n'a pas
marché en tout cas à ce jour le rouble
est revenue à son niveau d'avant
la crise
et ça c'est on va dire pour venir
poutine c'est une victoire mais en tout
cas c'est même une sacrée bonne nouvelle
parce que s'il avait à gérer en plus
tendrement monétaire de son pays ça
serait assez terrible maintenant on va
voir ce qu'il en est dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois la
d'ores et déjà ils ont les russes ont
annoncé qu'ils couper le gaz à la
pologne et à la bulgarie j'ai donc du
côté du gaz allemand a acheté par les
russes alors je précise effectivement
n'aura nous dit ne dis pas qu il coupe
le gaz mais que le gaz doit être payée
en rouge ou en or ce que la pologne et
la bulgarie oui c'est absolument nous là
là je parlais de larmes ultime qui lui a
coupé le robinet est effectivement entre
les deux cas demandait poutine et ce qui
était malin politiquement c'était
d'exiger
des occidentaux qu'ils payent leur gaz
et leur pétrole en roubles ce qu'est ce
que vous alliez en termes économiques
c'est à dire que les européens doivent
acheter du rouble pour payer les russes
et si vous achetez du rouble vous faites
monter le rouble donc elle les sanctions
financières qui font baisser le rouble
mais les européens font monter le rouble
en en rachetant pour acheter leur gaz et
en pétrole alors comme pour les
européens s'étaient pas admissible de
céder au chantage russe ils ont trouvé
une solution intermédiaire non qui paye
gas en en euros qu ainsi de convertir
enfin ils ont trouvé un mécanisme
financier mais dans les faits ça revient
à peu même maintenant la question c'est
la prochaine étape on sait que les
européens sont prêts plus ou moins un
embargo sur le pétrole a encore
probablement sur le gaz mais ça pourrait
venir parce qu'on est encore dans le
cadre d'un conflit de longue durée et la
question c'est qui tiendra le plus
longtemps la russie il va avoir des
problèmes économiques indubitable du
fait d'un manque d'exportation ou les
européens vont avoir un coût en terme
d'inflation qui va être très élevé la
france elle a une inflation à 4 et demi
pour cent mais parce que il ya la
première il ya eu des il ya eu d
non mais c'est déjà élevé et c'est
beaucoup moins élevés qu'ailleurs en
europe puis c'est parce qu'il ya eu des
contrôles des traits sur l'énergie dans
les pays européens où il n'y a pas ces
contrôles on est déjà une inflation à
10% absolument énorme donc combien de
temps les populations européennes
l'accepterons je pense que c'est aussi
l'un des paris de poutine qui se dit que
avec le temps le l'unité des européens
et des occidentaux va se fissurer et qui
pourra jouer là dessus on a une dernière
question sur les sur l'expression des
négociations une des négociations entre
poutine et zelensky elles sont pour
l'instant c'est pas du tout d'actualité
ce n'est pas l'histoire du jour pas du
tout d'actualité les il crée avec les
mac de le bout de chalais les ukrainiens
peuvent pas
et par ailleurs on là il ya des chacun a
des enfants tous cas surtout les russes
elles ont des objectifs militaires
donc il faut attendre les négociations
peuvent venir que quand l'un ou l'autre
des belligérants pense avoir obtenu
quelque chose de suffisant pour entamer
des négociations donc c'est c'est trop
tôt encore une fois ce qu'il faut bien
se dire c'est que là on est entré dans
une guerre longue très bien merci
beaucoup alexis et d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui merci au service infographie
bien évidemment nous avoir fourni ces
cartes que nous vous avons diffusé merci
à la modération aussi qui a été et est
très utile aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il
y avait beaucoup de commentaires
beaucoup de questions bien évidemment si
vous voulez continuer à suivre ses lives
bien sûr vous pouvez vous abonner sur
une chaîne youtube postée chaîne twitch
pour ne rater aucun live bien sûr
abonnez vous aussi au figaro pour voir
tous les reportages qui sont très
intéressants qui sont publiés tous les
jours sur sur l'ukraine merci une
nouvelle fois l'ex merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été présent et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro là